have to mention please
today's discussion is going to be on the
record and it is being live streamed
we encourage people who are going to
contribute through social media to use
the
#ch events there as it has written on
the screen and at Chatham House
I will be as I say moderating the
discussion but also calling on people
here who want to ask a question if they
would like to do so there will be a
microphone you don't need to stand up
just raise your hand and somebody will
come and find you and anyone who is
online who'd like to ask a question
please submit it in writing and I will
do my best to read out your question and
see whether it is for Paddy or for Lisa
to answer so that's the way we will do
that what we're going to do is uh I will
just introduce briefly to distinguished
guests Lisa will speak for eight or ten
minutes or so
I might or might not exercise my
privilege of being here to pick up a
point or two that she's made Patty
McGinnis will then speak and then we'll
have a bit of a orchestrated discussion
between us before we throw it open to
the floor everything to be finished in
um in 60 minutes sharp so we'll see how
we get on now we're here today to talk
about disrupt Technologies by nation
states and malign cyber actors and by
extension how the UK and U.S governments
are dealing with them disruptive
Technologies cover a multitude of sins
chip manufacture artificial intelligence
algorithms abusive facial recognition
software the exploitation of restricted
Technologies attacks on our critical
infrastructure phone hacking social
media manipulation data theft and much
else including the odd spy balloon
Flying high in this space so we've got
lots to talk about and a couple of real
experts and I'm thrilled really thrilled
that Lisa is here we've dealt with each
other in Washington and elsewhere over a
number of years and she's a dear friend
and we're very pleased that she's here
for those of you who don't know all
about her distinguished career I'm going
to embarrass her by running through a
little tiny bit of who Lisa Monaco
really is
Deputy Attorney General of the United
States the 39th of that ilk and as such
she is the number two person in the
Department of Justice and essentially
does all the overall supervision of the
doj she advises and assists the Attorney
General in formulating and implementing
the Department's policies and programs
she's been with the Department of
Justice for many years she was a career
Federal prosecutor and has been in a
number of leadership positions across
the department
she used to work for Janet Reno who was
the Attorney General when I was first in
Washington during the Clinton
Administration and I remember spending a
lot of time with Janet and I think we
were probably in the same room uh there
and then so it goes back a long way
she's had a number of leadership roles
she was chief of staff at the FBI and
then when we saw a lot of each other was
when Elisa became
I've got to get the terminology right
Homeland Security and counter-terrorism
advisor to the president when President
Obama was in the white house and I had
the privilege of being our ambassador
there so we did a lot of things together
at that time and during that period when
Paddy was our Deputy National Security
advisor some of the time but he was also
doing another role in government he too
had the privilege of working closely
with Lisa on a number of these security
issues a wide range including responses
to International and domestic terrorism
threats cyber natural disasters and all
aspects of U.S government's policy on
counter-terrorism and counterterrorism
strategy Lisa was born and raised in
Massachusetts surprise surprise graduate
of Harvard University and of the
University of Chicago Law School
paddy the gentleman on the other side of
me said that
is now senior advisor at the Brunswick
group and former UK Deputy National
Security advisor these days he advises
businesses and governments around the
world on data and cyber issues business
resilience and geopolitical and
Regulatory risk he sits on the advisory
committee of the UK's reinsurance pool
for terrorism risk and he advises the UK
parliament's joint committee on the
National Security strategy
from 2014 to 18 he was the UK's deputy
and National Security adviser for
intelligence security and resilience
and that included dealing with risk and
reactions to risk on all aspects of
Hazard threat National crisis response
coordination cyber strategy
counterterrorism and so on these days he
is also advising some private Equity
Funds and another number of technology
and other startups so he's a busy boy as
well Paddy we're thrilled that you're
here but enough of me Lisa over to you
and we are looking forward with enormous
interest to hearing your remarks
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much sir Peter and uh good
afternoon everyone I really want to say
thank you to Chatham House for having me
here today and thank you very much to
all of you in the room for that very
warm welcome I also want to acknowledge
our terrific Ambassador Jane Hartley who
is here today it is she is a long time
friend and is a tremendous Ambassador
for our government here in the UK to
Steward our special relationship and so
I really appreciate her being here I
think it says something about the wisdom
of our respective governments that the
UK and his Majesty's government has also
sent another fabulous woman to be the
UK's Ambassador in the United States I
am of course speaking of Dame Karen
Pierce who we are very fortunate to work
with in Washington so uh great to have
you here Jane it is great to share a
stage with sir Peter and with Patty who
are themselves two great UK leaders in
National Security and foreign policy and
as Peter mentioned also dear friends and
former colleagues when I served as
President Obama's homeland security and
counter-terrorism advisor
in those days our work as Peter noted
focused on counter-terrorism and on
Cyber threats and new challenges in both
of those arenas
today though uh those core those
challenges are very much still with us
and still present but today the U.S and
the UK and our allies Stand Together
against new threats
threats posed by and threats from
autocracies projecting power at home and
abroad
threats from adversaries challenging
Norms from launching spy balloons to
unleashing the most significant land
invasion in Europe since the Second
World War
and of course threats from nation states
Rogue Nations seeking to undermine
democracy and the rule of law
now we see this aggression playing out
not only on battlefields but in economic
zones and information spaces in cyber
attacks and the vacuuming up of
sensitive data and the exploitation of
restricted Technologies
we also are seeing some countries
threatening our national security
through foreign investment
investment designed to access sensitive
data and key Technologies
today autocrats seek tactical advantage
through the acquisition use and abuse of
disruptive technology
innovations that are fueling the next
generation of military and National
Security capabilities
they of course want to acquire that
technology by any means possible
not only to fuel surveillance and
repression at home and abroad
but to gain strategic dominance
the U.S and the UK and our allies
confront these National Security
challenges daily and in the United
States the Department of Justice is at
the center of our efforts working with
our allies to combat these threats
as the lead law enforcement and domestic
counter-intelligence agency in the
United States the justice department is
uniquely positioned with our dual
National Security and law enforcement
authorities and missions to respond to
this threat landscape and that is
exactly what we are doing
our prosecutors our agents and analysts
use law enforcement tools often in novel
ways to counter National Security
threats and we use our intelligence
tools
to provide policy makers the Vital
Information they need to shape how we
respond
we are disrupting cyber attacks
enforcing sweeping sanctions analyzing
foreign investments in U.S businesses to
detect and to deter Bad actors
all to protect American Technology and
know-how from being exploited by our
adversaries
first when it comes to cyberspace we see
nation states often acting in concert
with criminal groups in a new Blended
double threat
engaging in more sophisticated and
Brazen and dangerous attacks
they are threatening core public
institutions like our hospitals and our
schools with ransomware attacks and they
are routinely probing our critical
infrastructure for vulnerabilities
they use cyber armies and proxies
hackers for hire
and organized criminal networks in ways
that flout International norms and risk
our collective security
as we've done before against terrorism
we are working with our allies and our
partners to combat cyber threats by
innovating and using new tools to turn
the tables on the hackers
last year for instance working with our
partners in the UK in something called
operation Cyclops blink we disrupted a
global botnet a botnet that was
controlled by the gru
the Russian military intelligence agency
we disabled Russia's control over these
devices before and I emphasize before
they could be deployed in an attack an
attack against Ukraine against us or our
allies
our work collectively with our partners
protected innocent victims in the United
States in the UK indeed around the world
now this leads me to the second threat
that we face
the weaponization of data
personal data is of course the fuel for
our adversaries
both surveillance and intelligence
States
whether it's through traditional or
corporate Espionage our adversaries are
targeting troves and troves of data
as our intelligence Community has noted
China leads the world in using
surveillance and censorship to keep tabs
on its population to repress dissent and
to counter perceived threats abroad
and the Chinese government is not just
hacking to gather our data China's
doctrine of civil military Fusion means
that any advance by a Chinese company
with a military application must be
shared with the state
and its National Security Law requires
any company doing business in China to
make its data accessible to the
government
so if a company is operating in China
and is collecting your data it's a good
bet that the Chinese government is
accessing it
now the weapon the ability rather of uh
to weaponize data will only Advance over
time
as artificial intelligence and
algorithms enable the use of large data
sets in new and sophisticated and
increasingly sophisticated ways
the data obtained today could be used in
new and very frightening ways tomorrow
now this brings me to the third piece of
the threat landscape the National
Security threats posed by the use and
abuse of disruptive Technologies by
autocratic governments
no matter what means they employ whether
it's cyber Thrift theft or sanctions
evasion or exploiting foreign investment
we must guard our Technologies from
adversaries who would use them against
us
the Department of Justice is using all
of its tools all of its authorities to
combat this threat fighting cyber crime
combating sanctions evasion and most
recently updating our regulatory tools
to ensure we protect against foreign
investments that threaten our national
security
now for decades the United States has
screened foreign investment in U.S
companies for potential National
Security risks
through the committee on foreign
investment in the United States known by
its acronym cypheus
the justice department helps prevent
foreign threat actors from exploiting
those Investments to acquire U.S assets
and Technology while supporting the
benefits that flow from open investment
but cepheus began nearly 50 years ago in
an era of brick and mortar transactions
but today
the greatest risk comes not only from
investments in our physical assets
but from transactions where data sets
software and algorithms are the assets
that's why we've sharpened the focus of
cepheus on transactions that pose a
threat to data security to cyber
security and the resilience of our
critical Supply chains
President Biden has directed now that
cepheus consider if foreign investments
in a particular industry made over time
threaten National Security or our own
technological leadership
but I think we also need to consider
that risks from foreign investment run
in both directions
we must also pay attention to how our
adversaries can use private investments
in their companies to develop the most
sensitive Technologies to fuel their
drive for military and National Security
Edge
so we are exploring how to monitor the
flow of private capital in critical
sectors and ensure that our own outbound
investment in dual use Technologies
doesn't provide our adversaries with a
national security advantage
close collaboration with the UK will be
crucial to getting this right
now Beyond foreign investment screening
we're also employing other tools to
control the exports of critical
Technologies last fall President Biden
signed the chips act to ensure U.S
leadership in global chip production the
act invests in critical chip research
and Manufacturing and restricts the
transfer to adversary Nations where
those transfers pose a national security
risk
at the same time our Commerce department
has imposed new export controls on
Advanced Computing and semiconductor
components cracking down on the prc's
ability to acquire certain high-end
chips
justice department prosecutors will be
vigorously enforcing these new rules as
well as those that control other
sensitive Technologies
and that's why today I'm excited to
announce the launch of a new initiative
the disruptive technology Strike Force
a collaboration of U.S law enforcement
led by the justice and commerce
departments this Strike Force brings
together our top experts to attack
tomorrow's national security threats
today
we will use intelligence and data
analytics to Target illicit actors we
will enhance our public and private
Partnerships to harden our supply chains
and we will identify early warning of
threats to our critical assets like
semiconductors
our goal is simple but it's essential
to strike back against adversaries
trying to siphon off our best
Technologies
the Department of Justice is deploying
all its tools to respond to nation
states who would exploit technology to
undermine our alliances our national
security and the rule of law
but our most critical tool in this
effort is one we don't share or compete
with our adversaries for it's the power
of our Partnerships particularly the one
we have shared with the UK for so long
thank you so much for having me and I
look forward to the discussion
[Applause]
Lisa thanks so much I think the
announcement of the new disruptive
technology Strike Force I like the word
strikes just there's an initiative being
taken there uh it's going to guarantee a
certain amount of publicity and
headlines in advance of your trip to
Munich I've got a couple of other
questions I'd love to ask you but before
doing that I'm going to ask Paddy if he
would like to add to the debate and set
the scene a little bit from the UK
perspective
certainly thank thanks Peter and Lisa
wonderful to see you and wonderful to be
here with all of you I'd like to start
first of all by embarrassing Lisa so I'd
like to embarrass her this way so it's
clear to me in a way that it probably
won't be clear to any of you as the
person who used to sit first for David
Cameron then Theresa May looking at the
hazards and threats affecting to the the
United Kingdom what David Cameron used
to joke US ah here's the Deep State when
I strolled into the room
uh it was clear to me every day that the
work that Lisa has done and does now and
the agencies and organization that she
represents
that British citizens individually are
safer every day as a result of their
work and the real nature of that
Corporation is not apparent to most
people and that's true operationally
it's also true in the formation of
policy and thinking how we innovate
against Dynamic threats and difficulties
and critically innovating in a way that
is
lawful and proportional
which is a characteristic of Lisa's work
so I'm really pleased to have you here I
think just quick four quick points
as regards the United Kingdom so the
first one is
another thing that's very striking to me
is that the things that Lisa and I were
working on that were deeply Secret
in 2014 when we first started work
together are now profoundly public we
were worried about whether undersea
cables were secure yeah we were worried
about what was happening in the
telephony infrastructure on switches and
routers we were worried about
um how satellite downlinks could be
interfered with of course we heard about
cyber that was public and we were
worried about if you can interfere with
satellite downlinks what can you do to
GPS and what do you do when you have
critical National infrastructure that's
dependent not just on positioning but
critically on timing as a great deal of
national infrastructure is that was all
you know all funny colored paper and
special folders all that sort of thing
now it's part of the discourse not least
because we can see it manifest in the
electronic Warfare campaign that Russia
is mounting or has tried to mount
in Ukraine so that's cyber and the use
of disruptive technology writ large not
just can they interfere with my desktop
or my server or my routers
so and and it isn't it if we've come to
the end of Revelation about technology
so there's something dynamic in the way
that secret things things that are only
now perceived become public and become
part of the public discourse and need to
be dealt with and we need a policy
response secondly second Dynamic Factor
my word there's a lot of work yes in the
United Kingdom uh yes in the United
States as we just heard from from Lisa
but also in the European Union and
elsewhere and incidentally in China
to respond in terms of legislation
regulation and practice to these changes
in technology and and one just thinks
about the body of business that's going
through the British Parliament just at
the moment we've got the National
Security and investment act which is
bedding in we've got the National
Security Bill coming through of course
the Online
safety bill has implications in the area
that Lisa's talking about etc etc etc
and we have a restructuring of
government so there's the real Dynamic
aspect to the way in which government's
trying to catch up I would note still
most of our discourse though is about
technologies that or or about use of
technologies that it's already manifest
it's about
5G and the difficulties we've had we're
still talking about that with each other
it's about social media sites which have
already got penetration in our societies
for a profound degree so that's to my
mind something very exciting about what
Lisa say in terms of the strike force
because the thing I Most Wanted when I
was in government was to know what the
emerging technology risk was not just
what the squatting toad of an existing
problem was that I had to deal with it
just hadn't become public yet and she
wanted to try and get ahead of it and it
sounds like there's some potential there
now I work with businesses mainly listed
companies I do it globally
the third dynamism I see is the dynamism
of obligations upon leaderships in
companies
and there are people's legislation on
things of the blessed gdpr but there are
others too where they have to maintain
resilience where they have to have a
mechanism for understanding the risk
that there is in their practices
and the kind of discussions that we're
having the points that we're making the
points that Lisa hinted at there which
was doing a great deal about what
hostile States and other malign actors
are doing on effectively private sector
networks creates an obligation
under existing regulation legislation
and as there's Dynamic change to
regulation legislation more and more and
so this becomes something that boards
that Business Leaders have to deal with
and need help dealing with and and and
need a partner I'm sure we'll talk about
the wonderful work the Department of
Justice does and the FBI does to engage
with business there is a challenge and I
know in the UK we're thinking about that
at the moment not least in the
information of implementation of the
National Security investment Act
and then my final thought I talked about
Lisa
being proportionate
there is a real there's a real risk as
those who've got an understanding of the
emerging Technologies and how we need to
deal with them and their exploitation by
hostile States there's a real risk that
this turns into a broader discussion
about the Hostile State and we run the
risk economically of throwing out
not just the baby with the bath water
I'd argue the bath itself
and so there's something profound to my
mind in bringing together those who
truly understand the areas of technology
and the problems they represent on
public or private sector networks or in
in any domain and countering them
specifically because it is in
specificity and Nuance that we're going
to be able to avoid significant economic
disruption as we do the necessary work
of National Security and that's a key
element of the proportionate response we
should be looking for in the leadership
we're getting from the Department of
Justice in my view
Patty thank you
um very striking listing to both of you
just how much has changed how much the
challenge has evolved since the first
years when we were working together on a
number of these issues much of it in the
dark
and I'm struck also by the way in which
making public a lot of the things that
we used to feel we could not make public
has been an extraordinarily important
instrument in our foreign and security
policy look at the way in which we
managed to call out what Putin was doing
in Ukraine and win frankly The Narrative
very quickly and show his lies to be
barefaced lies from the outset and not
be as scared as we used to be about
compromising sources so that we knew so
that we showed where we'd got our
information from we've evolved we've
moved on and I think it's uh I think
it's very dramatic and it's a useful
additional element to our defenses and
so much more of what you guys are
dealing with now is in the public domain
and that means that people are more
aware of the risks and it means also
that the bad guys are a little bit more
on the back foot
um one little comment
um
Lisa you mentioned the way in which we
worked together and you talked about the
wonderfully named Operation Cyclops
blink I wonder who came up with that
um in the context of the new strike
force that you've just described do you
think you could give us a little bit
more of an idea of how you see the
United States working with close
Partners such as the United Kingdom to
make it work
I find it interesting that both of the
leaders that we worked for respectively
had nicknames for their Homeland
Security and counter-terrorism advisors
I was interested to find out yours I
just learned that mine was Dr Doom from
President Obama because my uh portfolio
as Peter talked about was everything
from natural disasters to terrorism to
cyber so when I darkened the door that's
what he called me so you got you you and
I can compete for for good nicknames
um so to respond to your question Peter
first I think
um you know the strike force I talked
about I think is perfectly in line with
our long history of uh partnership
whether it's intelligence and National
Security work uh whether it's law
enforcement cooperation you know I think
about what we're able to do in the Cyber
front as we mentioned with operation
Cyclops blink as I think about what our
countries have done working with our
allies to push back against Russia's
unprovoked and brutal aggression in
Ukraine through the work we've done
cooperatively and collectively to impose
first sweeping sanctions really on an
unprecedented scale and then to enforce
them to make sure that they have real
bite and to ensure that it has an impact
yes on on limiting Russia's access to
the Global Financial system but very
importantly to also hinder Russia's
capability ability to build up and fuel
its war machine that is only
accomplished by our Collective work
together to spot that sanctions Invasion
and go after it so in this instance with
the strike force what I Envision us
doing is pooling our experts in the
United States our work our prosecutors
Nationwide are experts on the technology
that is at risk and working with both
the intelligence and National Security
and law enforcement communities across
the United States and yes with our
partners what are the insights that we
can glean and use together to Target
those uh those export Supply chains that
may be misused and abused to fuel that
the abuse by autocratic governments of
this disruptive technology so I see it
completely in line as we have benefited
from those relationships for so many
years whether the threat is the evolving
Terror some threat whether it's the
evolving cyber threat and now today the
very real and present threat posed by
governments that seek to leverage
technology and innovation in a way to
repress their populations and to fuel
their military advantage to our
Collective National Security risk
thank you very much can I ask you also a
little question about whether there's
more we can do to increase our
Collective resilience
people are asking does end-to-end
encryption make us safer or less safe
and there's a debate going on in many of
our capitals about that and should we be
banning completely access to our markets
to our societies of some of those
commercial entities like Tick Tock and
the chairman of the Foreign Relations
Committee here recently told a
television anchor while I happen to be
watching it you know you've absolutely
got to scrap get rid of your app from
tick tock on your telephone because it
is a security risk to your personal
welfare
um we've already done some of those
things with Huawei but what about that
should we be going further in the
direction of of no longer have anything
to do with the firms which we believe
might be Trojan horses
a lot to
hear penny response to some of this as
well first on I get this question a lot
on end-to-end encryption is it made it a
safer or less safe I wholeheartedly
reject the premise
of that of the way that's postured first
there is no doubt of the benefits that
we individually collectively in our
nations gain from end-to-end encryption
full stop it is vitally important to
privacy to safety to cyber security
but I also think we have to recognize
that encryption is being used to my mind
as both a sword and a shield
it's being used as a terrific Shield as
I as I indicated to protect our cyber
security our privacy Etc but it's also
being used by US as a sort by uh
nefarious actors by illicit actors uh to
conceal whether it's terrorism plotting
whether it's the horrific
um uh you know distribution of of
um online images that brutalize and
manipulate and abuse young children and
a host of different ways so I think that
we we really do need to get out of this
false dichotomy about whether it's a
it's an either or proposition I think we
as the United States as the United
Kingdom and other rights respecting
nations
are not should not be in
a position and I don't think that we are
to basically say it's it's an either or
we can both protect
human rights and Public Safety and
Achieve great benefits for
the freedom of expression
Etc that all derives from the use of
encryption but I know I'm sure Patty's
got some and I'll respond to your Tick
Tock that comment in a minute but it
Patty may have a thought on the
encryption issue yeah I'd like to add a
level so I mean I fundamentally agree
with you and I do see enter undergoing
encryption as as essentially neutral and
exploitable by bad guys as well as good
guys and we can give specific examples
I
I put my point about dynamism and the
dynamism of the obligation being placed
upon business
so many businesses now say you know are
our networks fully encrypted and if not
let's make them fully encrypted
and they uh and they do their work then
to do that their internal networks and
they get as much as possible and
the difficulty for them is that's great
if the monitoring of that traffic and
the implementation of the encryption is
done well if it isn't done well you find
that there's in traffic you thought was
encrypted that actually the certificates
out of date went right or it isn't fully
encrypted and actually therefore you can
scrape data from it from the data flow
or you find that you don't monitor it in
your security operations center and it's
being used by adversaries I mean that
was one of the things that happened in
colonial pipeline it happened in other
attacks too so encryption is really
quite complex and as a business leader
trying to run a business doing something
which isn't an encryption company it's
delivering something else it's really
tricky because you think I've done a
thing that's made me more secure but
actually what you've done is you've
created a new set of tasks in order to
monitor whether or not you're secure and
every time we engage with businesses in
what we're doing is adding to the weight
of what they have to do to maintain
their security so being very clear about
what these security tools we introduce
are how we monitor them what the
regulatory obligation is really
important I know to me at least a
product can expand on it but maybe not
here you don't want to I should think
because it's probably won't address the
audience that much I note that the USG
the US government has recently required
all public bodies to do a review of
their cryptology effectively of the
cryptological Holdings and practices
because of what I've just described
so so this is a complex area and it's
not just a good if we encrypt end to end
everything will be Splendid no it's more
complex than that more nuanced but I
think that's exactly right and look our
leaders have have said quite clearly and
I think this is exactly right you know
tightly controlled lawful access is
vital absolutely vital to National
Security to Public Safety uh for all the
reasons um I think that that Patty
mentioned
um on your on your Tick Tock question
um obviously it won't talk directly
about
um the review that is ongoing in the
United States but I'll say this
um you know I spoke in my remarks about
the
um The Perils of
Chinese companies being subject to
Chinese National Security laws and other
and American companies so any company
doing business in in China for that
matter is subject to China's national
security law which requires turning over
of data to the state and uh there is a
there's a you know there's a reason we
need to be very concerned and I think
the foreign secretary's comment you
mentioned is is well taken I will note I
don't use tick tock and I would not
advise anybody uh to to do so because of
these concerns and look the bottom line
is China has been quite clear that they
are trying to
um you know mold and you know put
forward the the use and Norms around
technologies that Advance their and
privilege their interests those
interests that are not consistent with
our own their interests which are fueled
by and direct toward an authoritarian
approach to to their government and that
is not consistent with our own
Thank you Lisa one last question for me
if I may before we throw it open to
perform to others you've talked uh in
your remarks about placing controls on
exports of critical Technologies and you
talked about the chips act and some of
the other measures that the United
States has taken in this domain question
really is there a risk that limiting or
barring other states access to our
Technologies encourages them to develop
their own and then that we have no
oversight at all over that technology
and that they start operating in ways
which are even harder for us to manage
than if they are using technologies that
we've produced and as sort of second
half of the question
is there a risk of damaging the kind of
rules-based WTO trading order by placing
these unilateral restrictions if you
like on trade with other countries in a
way that threatens our overall
Prosperity I noticed this morning that
U.S China trade has gone up to 700
billion dollars last year it's quite
significant in terms of of the growth
agenda so look I think you raised some
very very important points all which
have to be considered as we Embark uh on
and navigate this space
um I think what it means is we have to
be incredibly thoughtful about how we go
about this to your first point though
um you know the point I spoke about when
we talk about our concerns about foreign
investment I think the risk that you
pose is real but I would also push back
to say the Acquisitions that we're
concerned about are the acquisition of
our technology to fuel the creation of
their technology that is
creating a military and intelligence a
national security Edge and so it's it is
not it's not the concern that we're
going to create a really dueling silos
but really these are research they're
stealing it or acquiring it through
nefarious ends they're not using their
own um uh you know resources to develop
it and so that that is probably not good
for our Collective competition
um
we do though have to be quite thoughtful
in how we're doing whether it's about
inbound investment or outbound
investment which means conversations
with like-minded Nations uh but like
between the US and UK is is critically
important to getting it right it means
circumscribing uh for instance when I'm
talking about uh controlling and
monitoring and being mindful about the
dangers about outbound outbound
investment
um it has got to be focused I think on
private capital in very specific
Industries and sectors things like
semiconductors things like Quantum
Computing but not broadly
um
you know not not applying a broad brush
to this approach
Paddy did you want to um one question
yeah one question for me so
So Lisa that you're framing of that deep
not Broad
how do governments
communicate with business
so that they understand
what is required and you don't have
broad deadening effect I know it's
something we're wrestling with here in
the UK at the moment with the
implementation of National Security
investment act where we don't want to
have broad suppressive effect on inward
investment but there are some very
specific areas but until you know we
have the maturity perhaps insiphius it's
hard to communicate that depth as
opposed to that breadth what's the best
way of going about that what would your
advice be to the British government
simply I simply put I'd say by doing it
right I think you've got to be
communicating
um and we need to do it more and better
with our private sector I think
as you know better than now because
you're you know better than I now
because you're out of government but
fundamentally I think this is one
certainty they want Clarity right so the
more we can communicate the things we
are concerned about the why and how we
are going about thinking about that kind
of uh you know small yard tall fence
approach I think the better off we'll be
can I make it just a quick observation
when I look at the American system
I look at people like Lisa I could name
people who are now in the National
Security Council and elsewhere in
government who are developing these
policies all of them have been out in
business or legal practice
in a way dealing with technology cyber
and data issues in a way that we don't
have that advantage in the UK that we
don't have a leadership who are doing
the security work who are actually been
exposed to the realities of business and
the realities of what it is like to be
in a boardroom with a fiduciary duty
okay it's very different
you and I end up with doing that after
we've done the government service
okay can I look around the room and see
who'd like to ask a question
hello one here front row
dynamism of companies and in my
experience I've seen some ambivalence
around regulatory powers and what
happens within businesses when you
consider the backdrop of threats whether
that be botnets from gloryu or the MSS
infiltrating Supply chains of major
commercial airlines it's clear that
technology isn't the only way to combat
the threat what is the plan to engender
a culture of better side behaviors at
the organizational and individual levels
to create stronger resilience
so uh first what what I am trying to do
and what we are trying to do in the
Justice Department
um is send a message most importantly to
businesses uh the businesses that uh
let's face it in our country
um own operate control the you know 80
to 90 percent of the critical
infrastructure networks in my country
right which means that we in the
government are really incredibly
dependent and reliant on information
that we get from and reporting that we
can get from the victims of these uh
cyber attacks so that's why when we were
able to use a traditional law
enforcement and legal tool a forfeiture
warrant which is you know incredibly
boring if you think about it but it was
used in an incredibly new and Innovative
way in the wake of the colonial pipeline
attack we used that legal tool we in the
Justice Department government and the
FBI to do a very traditional thing when
you're talking about to somebody in law
enforcement we followed the money right
we followed the ransom payment that was
made by Colonial and
got it back right we got it back uh and
we're able to get back uh a bunch of
that Ransom payment and return it to the
victim uh and so that's why you saw me
get up uh in a press conference and do
something we don't normally do we talked
about the victim coming forward and
helping us and how vitally important
that is to our ability to help the next
victim and frankly prevent the next
victim after that so my message to
business is whenever I can make it is we
are all in this together when it comes
to particularly the Cyber threat and we
need that cooperation we need that
reporting you know we worked again with
our International Partners just a few
weeks ago to take down a uh The Hive
ransomware actors to the tune of um you
know being able to rest and prevent
rather over 130 million dollars in
ransomware payments that was thanks to
cooperation and great sleuthing by the
FBI and the justice department to
literally lion way and what I call the
21st century cyber Stakeout we were able
to watch and sit in that network network
for months get those decrypter keys and
hand them out to the victims so that
they wouldn't have their systems locked
up we were only able to do that because
of the reporting that we got from the
victims but
only 20 percent of the victims actually
reported think of what more we could
have done with even more cooperation so
fundamentally our orientation has
changed we don't want to re-victimize
the victim uh as the justice department
we want uh folks to come forward and
work with us and we want to be focused
and on our front foot when it comes to
preventing we will always going to want
to make sure we can lock up the bad guys
don't get me wrong but we also need to
focus first and foremost in the Cyber
threat to on the prevention piece
thank you
I'm back to you in a minute yes the lady
over there we'll hand up
thank you very much my name is Joyce
Hackman for Chatham House you spoke
earlier Deputy attorney general about
the connection between criminals and
nation-state actors and my question is
in relation to this story that broke
yesterday in the news about this Israeli
company that has been basically offering
this information as a service and
therefore intervening in elections
around the world so the the strive force
that you talked about is focused on
adversaries or threats coming from
adversive Nations and I wonder whether
this this Strife was also cover threats
that are emanating from an ally country
and if not how will the U.S continue to
deal with these threats thank you uh
thanks for the question I'm I'm not
going to respond to the specific issue
you reference I haven't seen that
article but I would just say broadly uh
yes we are focused first and foremost on
uh the use and abuse of uh these
Technologies by our adversaries because
we don't have that level of trust
because we know uh the
um the use that they are putting those
Technologies to and we don't have uh
that level of transparency and shared
values as we do with the UK and
generations of security cooperation and
shared values so yes that's our our
priority and because our first job in
the Justice Department is to enforce the
law and we have very specific export
restrictions on that technology to
specific countries for very good uh
intelligence and evidence-based reasons
so from the white top here if you can
bring the mic over
foreign
thank you all very much
um you and Grant I'm a former law
enforcement intelligence analyst in the
UK had responsibility for transnational
organized crime in the ex-soviet states
have subsequently worked in EU missions
particularly in Ukraine where many of
the male National staff were ex-soviet
military and several were quite
explicitly former giu if indeed former
my question is about Academia and I
think this is perhaps more a problem in
the UK and particularly Europe less so
in the US
is Academia both in stem work and
non-stem really engaged in working with
you all on this because I've had the
impression that large parts of Academia
can be a bit egotistical and they see
themselves rules above this and worked
too closely with Russia and China for
too long I accept that's a
generalization but where do you see that
from the UK us and to a certain extent
European situation thank you
start on the UK phone
sure well um
a great American colleague Keith
Alexander who was head of the National
Security Agency in the US for 12 years
has a great line which he uses which he
says which which frees me from having to
break the official Secrets out which is
where he says
um and then they say if we wanted to get
into somewhere we keep trying and we'd
get in
yeah and he's talking about all
varieties of Target networks so if we
start with the premise that we're going
to somehow make academic networks as
secure as the nuclear firing chain you
know there isn't going to be Academia
it's not going to happen so so I rather
than in a sense blaming the culture in
Academia I'd say that there is a
fundamental issue and that's recognized
I think in in British strategy and
response and it's a constant process and
it is palpable including incidentally in
the private sector that we're getting
drawn more and more into supporting
universities colleges and universities
and raising their cyber standards to
make them make it more difficult to get
in particularly particularly around the
most valuable assets that they have I
would note there's a very big
distinction I live near Oxford I look at
what is developed near around near
Oxford once you have something that is
of significant commercial value it's
noticeable that your cyber standards
change very much goodly very quickly and
so I I think it's a mistake just to lump
Academia together but you can see it's a
priority area you could you can see it
needs a constant support and it
absolutely is in the front line of what
Lisa is
um talking about uh with the strike
force
[Music]
is
um have more transparency around the
research dollars that are coming into
our universities that are particularly
those engaged in the hard sciences that
may be the targets of our adversaries
particularly those research institutions
that take Federal money and benefit from
federal money so I think it's about
transparency I think it's also about
having important uh trusted dialogue
between the law enforcement and National
Security Community within the United
States and Academia that is you know
that's easier said than done because for
for many good good reasons you know that
I think there is a as a zone of of care
that is that is taken in those
conversations but it's very important
for us to have them and to work at them
and to work to improve them
Lisa quick question from online audience
what is the level of threat currently
posed by cryptocurrency transactions
we are seeing is
um illicit actors using uh crypto
in ways that
um I think has is exploded quite frankly
whether it's the ransomware payments
that I mentioned recently with regard to
Colonial pipeline attack and others and
Myriad other cyber attacks whether it's
to hide sanctions evasion and to
facilitate sanctions evasion
to just do and fuel money laundering by
a host of illicit actors so what we're
doing in the United States so the answer
is the threat is going up
um but it is I think owing to the desire
of illicit actors to find any way and
they'll exploit new technologies to do
that to conceal their efforts but what
we're trying to do is go after the whole
ecosystem right so yes the illicit
actors that are using crypto and other
means to to hide their effort Parts but
also we need to ensure that the
exchanges that are hosting these and
facilitating these these payments
are good actors in this system uh need
and they should be employing the kind of
know your customer rules that financial
institutions have for years and that
have benefited our Collective efforts
when it comes to the terrorism threat
when it comes to the Cyber threat that's
why you saw just a couple weeks ago us
again working with our International
Partners this is a theme Here folks that
we don't do anything in isolation to
take down and disrupt the use of the
bitslotto cryptocurrency exchange
notorious for fueling millions and
millions of dollars in illicit
illicit exchanges from drug trafficking
to money laundering so we've got to get
at the entire ecosystem used by illicit
actors to fuel their efforts to include
the use of crypto
don't do anything
just like to pick back
um
on that but also what Lisa was saying
about the technical Endeavor that
there's been out of the FBI and other
bodies in the U.S in pursuit of marine
actors online and I think
um we're just waiting for a Refresh on
our integrated review I think there's a
really interesting question given what
we face in the world about about whether
in the United Kingdom we are resourcing
and approaching this uh in a way that's
comparable with that in the United
States and whether or not we've got the
technical ability distributed across
government and law enforcement in the
way that they have in the us and what we
can learn from that because we should
all be clear we're on the upslope of
this I mean we're on the upslope of
ransomware Ransom payment to Beta
cryptocode there's no sense in which
we're on the downslope I've got it under
control you know I'm afraid to say on
Cyber crisis I make a very healthy
living supporting people who get
themselves in one way or another into
difficulty so you know there's work to
do here to have the National Technical
capability to work alongside the United
States in crime as much as in National
Security
let's have another quick question Patty
perhaps for you from the online audience
bearing in mind what you just said
is there a role for the United Nations
or bretton's Woods organization since
setting International rules and
standards around the limits of
artificial intelligence the use of
information and the way in which
individuals in individual human rights
are in Jeopardy as things stand do we
need more of an international
rules-based framework to deal with these
issues I think we need transparency
and to be transparent about you know
what is being done which algorithm is
doing what how artificial intelligence
is working Lisa and I had the joy of
trying to deal with
Chinese actors in British and American
networks and negotiate UK or U.S China
cyber agreements and and indeed try to
operate within the freight within the
government group of experts under the UN
around cyber and can I say this was slow
going
so so I'm slightly skeptical
um that going that route would actually
result in a real practical effect given
the way in which this is dynamic and
growing so we do need something
different on the other hand I do think a
growing understanding of growing
independent view of what is happening in
the information environment is needed
and I'm afraid to say I think it needs
to be neutral because the moment it is
our view of what's happening in the
information environment there's a whole
category of actor who we don't catch
with that and likewise we wouldn't want
the information environment simply to be
seen by adversely we generally need an
objective view on what is happening in
our information environment
thank you
other questions from the floor
let me take one from Over the side yes
hi brother
National
I I am wondering whether um what what
the threshold is essentially for the FBI
and authorities to become interested in
cyber attacks given that we know that
they've been individuals targeted
citizens of the United States and on top
of that are we kind of turning a blind
eye or extending
um more flexibility to Allied countries
who aren't as concerning as say Russia
and China our friends in the Middle East
or other authoritarian countries who are
using private organizations private
companies to hack into individuals to
hack into our infrastructure but also
investing into our utility companies in
the private sector as well so I'm
wondering while there's all this focus
on Russia and China are we ignoring or
not paying enough attention to other
avenues of hacking cyber attacks and
other violations of human rights and
extensions of that
well I think I would start by saying um
in partially in response to the question
from over here
um you know we have different Frameworks
that we can use and we are putting to
work as I mentioned before our export
control for instance
a framework to address the uh the abuse
by nation states and adversary Nations I
think we do have to be concerned about
where this technology is going and the
and the use it can be put to in the
commercial space and having the right
and having both transparency and legal
Frameworks around that certainly it's
something that we are looking very
closely at
and are quite mindful when it comes to
the government's use for instance of
commercial data right whether it's in
purchasing or or using commercial data
it's something we're having a very
robust conversation about
um over in the United States when it
comes to how should the U.S government
be benefiting from using and ingesting
in some instances commercial data to add
to the tools that we have that are kind
of behind the wall right I think there
is a lot of importance to that
conversation but we have to make sure
we're doing it in an open a transparent
way and certainly one that is done from
my perspective because this is what
we're focused on in the Justice
Department it is done consistent with
the rule of law consistent with our
Constitution and the statutory framework
that we operate under which applies very
specific protections particularly to U.S
persons
personally identifiable information
Lisa do you reckon we can squeeze in one
more question there was several hands up
over here the lady here
congratulations on the new Strike Force
ma'am I wondered if you'd comment on new
Focus particularly on the role of
platforms and data for the strike force
um from the perspective of a large
Global uh private sector Network
um do you see a role for
telecommunications companies how would
you like us to continue to partner and
collaborate with you
um Etc
well thanks very much um look we think
we will benefit greatly from that
ongoing conversation that I think we
have been able to have as a as a
government
um for instance in the in the Cyber
realm I think we can build on a lot of
those uh that kind of muscle memory that
we've developed for instance the
financial services sector uh working
with our Treasury Department working
with others across the U.S government we
have been able to have a conversation
and have a kind of mode of operation
that I think benefits both
um the for to to take the financial
services sector as an example
to benefit from the great work they've
done to harden there and make more
resilient their networks
um and to protect their networks and to
help us protect them I think the same
conversation should be happening and
will be happening around this Strike
Force when it comes to
companies and industries that are by the
work that we're doing so I think about
the ways that we can identify these
illicit actors
who are trying to evade whether it's
sanctions whether it's trying to evade
our export control regime that we will
use from for instance our fincen
reporting and the like right we can we
can harness those existing mechanisms
and build further conversations around
these new restrictions for instance from
the chips act to I think kind of raise
all boats if you will
Paddy final word
so on this question of
telecommunications I think we should all
be clear that the in the jurisdictions
where the Cyber environment is safer it
is because the backbone providers raise
the base standard of cyber security and
manage the data going through their
networks before you get to the point of
law enforcement intervention that's not
really part of our discourse about our
economic interaction with those
providers so if you look around the
world at how traditional backbone
provides are doing in the stock markets
and more generally they're a bit
vulnerable because they're squeezed but
yet they are our backbone when it comes
to cyber security and that isn't yet
present in the thinking or sufficiently
present in my view occasionally we have
interventions as we did I think there
was activism around BT and we saw you
know the announcement we'll certainly
call that in if that develops into
anything but it's rare so there's
something for my mind about really
understanding how significant this
partnership is for for keeping us secure
and making that part of government
interaction with that sector
thank you for that
um I'm afraid sorry to those I haven't
been able to call I think we are out of
time so uh Doctor Doom deep state
thank you both what was your nickname
then I can't remember
or unprintable
Chatham House has been doing this sort
of thing for 100 years or so and I think
this was the conversation right up there
with the highest standards that Chatham
House has got used to thank you both
enormously for your contributions you've
contributed enormously to our
understanding of these new and
complicated and technological challenges
uh Lisa we wish you bon voyage on to
Munich where you could carry on the good
work and telling the rest of the world
how we've got to work together to get
this right Thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign